okay give me one hand here i'll guess
you should stay in the vehicle okay
the other hand do you have any weapons
or anything on you sir
weapon no no weapon i'm leaving on you
i'll say my words
like that sorry anything on you that's
gonna hurt me or anything like that no
no anything will hurt you only my words
only my philosophy only what i believe
in
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 94
with maxine bernier maxine bernier is
the leader of the people's party of
canada
the most right-wing conservative party
in canada
he argues it's the only truly
conservative party currently in canada
maxime was recently arrested in manitoba
for not
quarantining they have their own
provincial 14-day quarantine when
entering
their province from another province
he's really the only person in canadian
politics throughout the last year
that has been against the lockdowns in
canada we spoke about his arrest
the beliefs of the people's party of
canada why he thought splitting from the
conservative party was necessary and his
party's position
on abortion immigration what he plans to
do with canada's massive debt
and more if you enjoy this kind of
content
or at least maybe learn something please
consider hitting subscribe
this episode is brought to you by hover
a domain name
vendor that's absolutely wonderful for
sponsoring me so if you need a website
show them some love if you're going to
buy one anyway so they keep sponsoring
me
something that makes hover special is it
has a ton of options for different
endings on domains
it has over 300 domain name extensions
to choose
from when building your brand online you
can end your website in dot blog
or dot diet or whatever instead of a dot
com if you so choose
i use hover for that reason adding a dot
something to your website can be a
better idea than a fullonnew.com
i personally own at least eight domains
i've bought every iteration of michaela
peterson that you guys can spell wrong
it's not your fault i was named after
mikhail gorbachev and nobody knows how
to spell that
i cannot recommend buying domains from
hover enough
check them out at hover.com mp
and get a 10 discount with that referral
link on
all new purchases make a name for
yourself with hover
again hover.com mp
and get 10 off on all new purchases
having a website's
super important for anyone with a
business i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
maxime bernier welcome to my podcast
thank you thank you for this invitation
i'm very pleased to be with you michaela
well it's very nice to meet you i've
heard all about you in
canadian news and i wanted to have you
on to discuss
the most recent piece of news which was
an arrest in manitoba i believe
so we should probably back up a lot of
my audience is american
could you give a brief background about
who you are and what you do
yes i'm i'm the leader of the people's
party of canada
it's a new political party we started
that party three years ago
i was a conservative i was a minister
under the harper
government i've been elected as a
conservative in 2006. i was
industry minister foreign affair
minister and
in 2017 i did run for the leadership of
the conservative party of canada
i didn't win with 49 of the vote
um and i tried to i had a very
conservative platform at that time
and i tried to convince the
establishment of the conservative party
of canada
and the leader at that time was ann
gusher to convince him to take some of
our ideas for the campaign the 2019
campaign
but he didn't take any of our ideas so
after
10 months uh i was not successful to try
to influence the establishment of the
conservative party of canada
and i decided to quit and i said in a
press conference that
this party the conservative party of
canada is intellectually and morally
corrupt
and i said that because their only goal
is to
be in government is to be in power and
they don't want to promote conservative
values
so that's why we created the people's
party of canada we had our first
election
in 2019 we had about
1.7 percent of the vote um
that was not too bad for a new political
party because
michaela if you put that in the
perspective it took 20 years
and six elections for the green party of
canada to have more than 1.6 percent of
the vote
and now you know we will run on the same
platform
and i'm the leader of that party we may
have an election
this fall in canada and we are about
five six seven percent in the poll so
it's going very well this party will
grow
and we base that party uh on the four
principles
individual freedom personal
responsibility respect
and fairness and if you
want me to go back to your first
question about me being arrested
in manitoba that was i did a
tour mad max freedom tour because
we are the only political party at the
federal level that is against
these draconian lockdowns and and
i'm doing right now a tour across the
country speaking about that
and asking for our government to stop
these uh
draconian measures that uh provincial
governments are imposing to to us
so i wasn't mad i was supposed to be
manitoba
so i did an announcement and i went
there but just before
uh me being in manitoba at the premiere
of that province
mr callister did a press conference the
thursday before
i was there the friday and he said that
i was not welcome
and he sensed he said something like
that that if i'm coming
uh my wallet would be empty
uh so so i said you know and i received
also a letter from the head bureaucrat
for the health department in manitoba
telling me that if i'm going to manitoba
i will have to quarantine for 15 days
and manitoba as you know is in canada so
i'm a canadian i have the constitutional
right to travel across this country
so that was my answer to that bureaucrat
the db4
i said you know on twitter i have a
conscientious right to be
to travel and to be manitoba so when i
arrived in manitoba
as you know in canada we cannot have an
indoor
meeting it has to be outdoor and
i always did that i was in vancouver i
was in
edmonton calgary toronto and the way to
meet our people
because we will have an election this
fall um
it's to have meeting outside in a park
and i used to have this meeting outside
in a park with my team
to speak about the next election that is
coming and being sure that our party
would be ready for the next election
so i did two little uh meetings in a
little town in manitoba about an hour
south of winnipeg and the first one was
around
i think 10 o'clock in the morning we had
15 people in a park outside
and i'm i was speaking with my people
telling them that they'd have to be
ready
uh speaking about potential candidates
for our party for the next general
election
so and i was answering their questions i
i had planned to do a two public
rallies one that friday and another one
this
saturday afternoon at two o'clock in
winnipeg but before that
i did little uh meeting with my meeting
with my teams like that
so after that meeting i've been arrested
and they gave me two tickets
the first one was for not being in a
quarantine
and the second one is for being outside
in a park with more than five people
and the police said to me at that time
if you go to your second event second
meeting
you have a risk to be arrested so what i
did i called my lawyer and i
haven't had a discussion with him about
the their rules and
regulations in manitoba and he told me
that it's against our constitution
it's against charter of rights so i i
must go to my other
meeting but i will have a risk to be
arrested and
that was only that's very important to
say
michaela that was only you receive a
tickets at that first
at that first rally all the other
participants didn't receive any tickets
uh i really believe that it was a
political requestion
uh coming from the premier of that
province so i did the second event
around 1 30 p.m
the friday and we were in the park with
my team and
i don't know if you saw the photo the
picture but we were
only eight percent socially distanced
and i had a discussion with my team
about the
the candidate for that that writing and
just after that rally
and the police arrested me
uncuffed me and put me in jail like a
criminal
for a non-crime after a political
gathering
i was in jail for almost 10 hours
and the crown asked me for for me to be
free after that
to not communicate on social media
to not do any rallies all across the
country and a lot of conditions like
that
and also to give a thousand bucks for
for me to be sure
to be back in manitoba for my hearing uh
july
27 and my lawyer said okay for a
thousand bucks
bernie would be back for sure and we
will win that case
but we don't want any other conditions
uh you know
he's a politician is doing a campaign
will have an election he has the right
to speak and to campaign all across the
country
and the judge decided to um
to let me free with only
one kind of a condition that it was not
a condition anymore it was
just uh bernie must respect the law but
every canadian must respect the law so i
didn't have all these
conditions that the queen and the
prosecutor were asking so i was like
and i was free like i said 10 hours
before that
but the most interesting of that when i
it was about
11 o'clock or 12 o'clock at the end of
the day a friday friday night
um the police told me when i was three
mr bernie we will follow you
in that province and our advice to you
is to
leave manitoba as soon as possible uh
tomorrow morning
and um and i went to my hotel at that
time
and i changed my flight i was supposed
to do a rally at two o'clock
uh saturday afternoon in winnipeg so
i flew back to toronto and montreal uh
and when i was leaving my uh my hotel
just to cross because my hotel was at
the airport in dubai
when i was leaving my hotel uh rcmp
officers were there
not only one but two of them and they
were looking at me and they are
they asked me at that time are you going
to the airport to
uh to take your flight i said yes and
that was it and i'll be back in manitoba
i'll be back from the day of my hearing
or maybe before that
but that's why i said you know it's a
political repression
the premier of that province said
clearly in a press conference that he
didn't want me there
he didn't want any uh opposition or any
other point of view about
the cove the restrictions that he's
imposing on his people
it's unfair unconstitutional unjust and
again
our charter of rights so i will always
fight for what i believe
and that's why uh you know uh we
uh we did this party the people's party
will will fight for more freedom and
smaller government in this country
okay that's quite a story is it true
that
canada has one of the most restrict
the most restrictions out of anywhere in
the entire world
yes it was true now at this summer
we are a little bit more free but that
can they can come back with these
measures this fall but for example in
quebec in montreal we are we had a
curfew
from eight o'clock p.m to five o'clock
a.m we didn't have the right to go
outside
we had that curfew for about five months
uh in toronto he had a stay-at-home
order
um and also you you are you
were not able to uh in except in
manitoba it's still the case you were
not able to have
a meeting outside with more than two
people uh
so you're absolutely right uh if you
look at other
uh jurisdictions are there state in the
u.s
for example uh they opened their economy
and maybe early february and march of
this year
uh without everybody to be uh
vaccinated but here in canada uh
we we still had very strong lockdowns
until the end of may and um i'm scared
that
maybe this fall it will come back we
have to fight that and we will
but actually also in canada and
specifically in manitoba
the premier over there is uh is
thinking about uh thinking about having
a covey
19 passport and so that's uh
that would be against over our rights uh
people would
would be in a position to show their
covet passport before going to a
restaurant or things like that
in manitoba they are looking at that and
they may
want to impose one we are as you may
know against a vaccine passport because
that would be like in a communist
country
a kind of a country like show me your
papers if you want to do something
and that will create two two
kinds of citizens the vaccinated ones
and the unvaccinated ones
uh some of our fellow canadians will
have
privileges and order won't so we don't
want that kind of
that kind of country here in canada
how do you think this covid situation
would have been better handled
what would you have done if you'd been
in power
yeah like some other uh jurisdiction did
in florida
did very well in texas and you know some
expert assigned
a declaration the bollington declaration
and they were saying
since in the beginning that
we must maybe yes lock down the the
older people the more uh
the more people that are more than 75
years old because they're more in
denture
the most vulnerable people but we must
be able to live and open the economy and
so i think that that that's the best
solution it's the first time in the
history of the world
that we are locking down uh
populations to fight a virus that's not
the solution that was an experiment
and a failed experiment because now
after a year we have all the data and
the statistics
and we know that some states in u.s or
some other countries in europe
where they didn't have any lockdowns the
the numbers the number of cases were the
same
and so you know didn't that didn't
change anything
it's not about science anymore it's
about compliance and in canada we have
provincial authoritarian governments
that like their
emergency power and we are still in
quebec
under an emergency health uh order
so but there's no emergency anymore
usually an emergency
mikhail it's for a couple of days not
for 15 months
and um so so the best way to to manage
that crisis
would have been to protect the older
people
and let everybody do what they want to
do because for me
every business is essential and now
these
lockdown created more harms than good
because a lot of people were not able to
have their surgeries
and and the suicide
rate increase in our country so there's
a
collateral damages that are very high
for our population uh
you know businesses that closed and and
went bankrupt
so it was a big disaster
and that's why we are fighting against
these kind of measures do you think that
if nothing changes with the government
how long do you think these measures are
going to be in place for yeah so i i
it's it's a little bit better now and
i think this summer would be free again
in this country
businesses would be able to reopen
would be able to uh gathering in park
and going to a rock cancer
concert or things like that but
maybe this fall they will come again
with you with these uh
kind of uh lockdowns across the country
uh we may win the fight for this summer
but uh i believe that they will come
with other uh
during this fall so that's why i'm doing
that
mad max freedom tour across the country
and
and speaking for our freedom and for a
smaller government that will respect our
constitution and respect
canadians yeah
uh do you think so i'm in europe right
now i'm not in europe i'm in russia
right now
um and russia is fairly open
ours are restricted but there aren't
very many masks
the delta variant that's been around in
the news
and i'm always skeptical about what the
media is telling us whether or not it's
true
about what we're being told but the
delta variant does seem to be around
here um however
they're still not shutting everything
down so people are getting sick
they're getting better and the economy
is at least
still open so i like i would assume
if we do have a an increase in covit
again
in the fall or if other variants end up
getting in
canada will just shut everything down
again so i'm in agreement with you
and then we're going to be stuck in this
cycle for i have no idea how
long like especially given the fact that
some of these variants look like they
still hit people who are vaccinated
so i don't know i'm concerned about
canada is there
is there something people can do if
they're unhappy about the direction
canada is headed in
yes for sure mikhail i think they can
send a strong
message this fall because i believe that
we'll have an election this fall
and and you know to to say to these
establishment political parties
in canada the liberals the conservatives
the ndp the green party the black quebec
one quebec
that you know they don't like the their
their policies they don't like
what they what they believe in because
they believe in in lockdowns and they
think that's the right thing to do to
stop that virus
you're right about the variant uh we
have that variance also here in canada
but you know the solution is not to to
to kill the economy
and lock down everybody uh there's other
solution
and yes the the vaccine is there the
vaccine
seem to be efficient against that
variant
um but also you know if you uh have
had coffee you develop some unity also
so that being said uh what the what can
they do
uh we are the only political party that
is fighting for freedom
you know we don't believe in a big
government that i that would tell you
what to do in your day-to-day life
and i hope our party is going well in
the poor right now
we are growing we have more and more
people that are coming to our rallies
and if people want to have a big change
they can send a strong
signal to this politician i don't
believe i'm pretty realistic that i'll
be a prime minister of this country
after the next election
but this party is going and i don't know
what can happen
but for sure we will influence the
canadian political landscape in the near
future
and that's important for canadians to
vote for what they believe in
and not always voting against something
because i know that a lot of canadians
are tired and fed up with the trudeau
government
and and the best way to to to to vote is
to express your point of view about what
you believe
and the more people would be elected
under the ppc
banners that more people would be
elected for a party
uh we will be up there and we'll be able
to influence the national debate
now it's very difficult for us the
mainstream media is cancelling me
uh they don't want to hear that point of
view you know the point of view on
the other point of view on covey 19 or
the other point of view that we have on
different policies
um so but that's why i'm traveling
across the country and need canadians
i think there's a hope there's a hope if
everybody stand up and speak out about
what they believe
and they must speak to their friends to
their colleagues to their
family about the situation and and what
they think about that
uh i strongly believe that there's a
silent majority out there that are
looking at
us the minority and they're not so sure
they don't have the
the courage to act or the courage to to
to speak
and i'm telling them you must speak like
when i was arrested
uh the police asked me um if i have any
weapons on me
and if i have something that can hurt
him you know that was the first time
that i was arrested i didn't expect a
question like that from a politician
that is traveling across the country
i don't uh travel with weapons on me
and so my answer uh when he said that i
was surprised i said weapons
no i said only my words only my
philosophy
only what i believe in and that's that's
my
weapon we need to speak we need to be
out there we need to be
uh vocal on social media i know it's a
little bit more difficult because now we
have the
big tech corporations that are censoring
us
but we need to speak we need to stand up
we need to speak out and
if we all do that i think we'll need
that we
will will uh will show the road uh the
path for for the majority of canadians
and and and that will be only the
beginning of a new way of
of do doing politics in canada
i hope so um so you split off from the
conservative party have you been
concerned that
that might fracture the vote that's a
good question michaela
and uh that was the the big argument
that the conservative
had against us that the regional
election in 2019
they were saying you know if you want to
get rid of just thanks for do
you need to vote for us we are the only
option that can be in government and so
you you'll be uh you'll be happy with it
uh so when i was campaigning at that
time
a lot of canadians came to me and they
were telling me maxim i like what you're
doing i like your platform you're a real
conservative
party but i want to get rid of your
saints redo and i will support
the conservative and usher and that was
an argument that was
very efficient for them
but i can tell you that this is changing
a lot because i was in alberta
and i was in vancouver maybe a month ago
and people came to me and they are
telling me maxime
sorry i said sorry for what i didn't
vote for you
because i didn't want to split the vote
i wanted to get rid of justin trudeau
but this time i will vote for you and
i'm i'm i'm very surprised and i'm
asking why
and that's a good news for for us
and and they are telling me because we
know that the conservative won't win
aaron o'toole won't win the next general
election in canada
i don't want to waste my vote and this
time
i will vote for what i believe i will
vote for my values and i will vote for
you
so the big difference with the last time
and this time
now and people know that
maybe just thank you will win it's not
the best
choice for them but they're ready to
have a liberal government for four years
uh if they have a strong voice with the
people's party in
people's party of canada in parliament
speaking for them
and and influence the debate over there
and that's
most important that uh they elected
uh candidates from the people's party of
canada for their voice to be uh
on to be here and to be in parliament
and debating
so that's a very good news and now who's
fitting the vote
it's eren utul and the conservative
their goal is to split the liberal votes
and because they're going to the left
they're going to the left because
their only goal is to be in government
is to be in power
and now we are in a socialist era in
canada
and in north america and and for them
they think that the only way to win the
easiest way to win
rapidly is to be leftist because about
65
70 percent of the population is
socialists right now
so they're going to the left with the
trudeau government
and the liberals and they try to split
the liberal votes
but that won't win uh you know and they
are helping
uh the leftists doing that because they
are giving more credibility
to to their policies to their
crazy policies and so so for us
we are now the only conservative party
uh on the right in canada and and i
think we have a
good opportunity for for this election
to elect
some candidates and and being part of
that national debate again
okay those are good points it's been
it's been strange watching
canada in the last year and a half with
covid because you look at the states and
there's
kickback in some areas like you said
texas
florida in some of the more conservative
states they've said we don't want
lockdowns we're not okay with this
and it seems like that hasn't been
anywhere in canada
which is it's scary that there isn't
that
section to fight back against things
which means that these
the situation with covet could just last
for i don't know how long every time a
new variant comes out
just like lockdown repeatedly crushing
the economy
it's been strange watching america have
these other factions when we don't seem
to so i suppose you're aheading
the main one politically and you're
right about that because
if you look in the in the states in the
u.s the
the more the fewer states are the one
that
the conservative one the republican one
and so
in canada it's the opposite you're
supposed to have conservative a
conservative government
in alberta with jason kinney you're
supposed to have a conservative
government in manitoba
with mr palistu you're supposed to have
a conservative government in quebec with
mr lego
they're all conservative government at
the provincial level
but but they're worse than socialists
the best provincial
government in canada was the ndp
government
a socialist government in vancouver in
british columbia
so contrary to the us are are
our conservative provincial governments
were worse than than the the socialist
one
and in the us it's it's it's it's the
best the logic you know if you are a
republican and you believe in freedom
you don't do any lockdowns
and where you have a blue state
um when you have a conservative
government like in florida in texas
in south dakota uh didn't have any
draconian lockdowns uh measures
hmm interesting okay so
if you if we didn't have covid to deal
with
which we're we do for the next for the
foreseeable future
what would you be focusing on i'll be
focusing on
and i'll try to do that during the next
campaign on the prosperity and unity of
our party
of our country sorry uh as you may know
in alberta
35 of the population over there uh
want to separate from canada the
independent test movement
in alberta is very huge so but
there's no mainstream political
leaders no one is speaking about that
they don't want to
to to speak about that and i think it's
important and they want to
to separate from the country because
they think that
it's unfair what is unfair for them it's
the way that the
the the government is always interfering
in provincial jurisdiction
and they want more autonomy from for
alberta
so that's an important subject and we
have a solution for that we're ready to
to
to deal with it and the solution is
simple
to have a radical decentralization uh we
believe in provincial autonomy
and you know i'm coming from quebec and
in quebec we have
two national sport the first one is
hockey
and the second one is referendum we had
two referendums on separation and
and i understand their frustration out
west and canada
so we have a solution and the solution
is to respect the constitution giving
more
power to provinces more autonomy to
provinces
building pipelines in this country by
using the constitution because it's
under the
the jurisdiction of the federal
government and we can have pipeline and
as you know it's very important for our
oil and gas industry to be sure that
they will have access to
uh markets so so
they don't speak when i'm saying data
conservative the liberals they don't
speak about the western anime nation
and the solution is to have a radical
decentralization
that would be important for the next
campaign but the other thing also that
we must speak it's all the cancel
culture the woke uh the the loss of our
freedom freedom of speech
censorship on the internet as you may
know the
the liberal government just stable a
bill two bills
c10 and c36 and they want to regulate
what we are seeing
what we are doing on internet and
you know that's the beginning of a
censorship by
the government so we have already
censorship by the big
tech corporations and that would be
another kind of censorship
we cannot and they are doing that under
the the the title of hate uh hate crimes
uh but as as you may know in canada
less than one percent of all the crimes
in this country
are related to aid to speech so that's
not a problem
eight crimes is not a problem in canada
but they're using that to have a new
definition of
hate and and to regulate the internet so
maybe if you're saying something that
people
won't like you'll you'll be censored
that's something that cannot happen but
actually we have two bills in
parliament that are just doing that and
so that would be important for the next
campaign and as you may know
our party is fully uh against that this
bill
why is that something the government is
fixated on right now like why are they
pushing through
bills that would potentially limit free
speech under the guise of
yeah because he hated because they
wanted a competition
they don't want to have any dissident
saying something that they don't like
look the example
uh in manitoba my personal example
pallister didn't want me to speak
for telling people in my angel about the
truth about kovin19
and so they stopped me by putting me in
jail
so now they don't want uh they want
what i'm saying the the the government
and politicians in ottawa
uh liberal politicians in ottawa
want to control what we're seeing on the
internet
and the the the speech the speeches that
won't be
hate speech will be uh liberal and woke
speech and and the conservative thinking
uh will be the one that they they're
gonna tell us that oh it's a hate speech
so
we must uh stop that so
in the end they don't want any
competition of ideas
and and that's why i said that
on tucker uh fox news after uh
being arrested and i said you know in
canada i feel like i'm in a communist
country
and we need to stop that so i think
that's why
but uh you know i'm optimistic because i
believe
because it's not because an idea is not
that popular today
that an idea is not just and
and and the right one uh
our ideas of individual freedom personal
responsibility respect and fairness
are just and and fair and
the great ideas based on western
civilization
and they will win they will win but i
don't know when
and uh now we are a minority and that's
why i'm the only political party to
speak about
western civilization values and freedom
and
responsibility uh because that's that
is not that popular today uh but
my my my goal is the more i will speak
about them
the more i will have support and and we
will grow
and we will we will be able to win but i
don't know when
but right now the trudeau government is
doing everything
to stop us to to to speak and to be out
and to explain
our philosophy what we believe in
i can't believe more people aren't up in
arms about the fact that
the government is limiting or
is has the power to limit what you see
on the internet
what they define as hate speech which
could be
anything right now it's
not yeah you're right but the propaganda
coming from the government
is is is huge i'll give you an example
in quebec for example the provincial
government
spend more than 145
million dollars last year only in
ad on the coving 19 in propaganda on
coving 19.
that was most than all the other
provinces together
and so in quebec in january
people were asking for more lockdowns
they were asking for more curfew
that's why the government was very keen
to to impose a curfew and to impose
lockdowns
because they scared the population with
their big budget their big propaganda
budget
and people were asking in quebec
five months ago for more long dawns so
so
and that's the same thing you know the
the propaganda budget coming from the
federal government
is huge and so the trudeau government
did the promotion that
eight speech is very important and it's
a big crime in canada
a big challenge that we have and so we
must do something
and the population believe that but when
you put the that time the statistic
and there's less than one percent of all
the crimes in this country
that are related to hate speech
that's not a problem we must not speak
about that
and actually there's a definition of a
hate crime
in the criminal code and that's okay we
don't need
a new definition that will be more
uh that that will be larger
and that definition will uh
will send the bureaucrats would be
evolved with that new definition to
censor us on social media
yeah because it's vague implement a new
law and make it vague so that it can
mean whatever you
want to mean and and the bureaucrat
would be able to interpret
and do what he wants with with that new
definition
yep uh okay so you went over some of
your
some of your goals if covid wasn't such
a big deal but it's a big deal and it's
probably going to be a big deal for the
next
number of years is there any news on
them removing the mandatory hotel
quarantine
anytime soon or is that staying in place
that's thing place for now and actually
i was
in niagara uh niagara falls
on the border of the us and canada and
i was on the bridge called the rainbow
bridge with uh
with canadians and on the other side
americans were there
and we did a protest last saturday on
that bridge
actually just to ask for that americans
want to to be able to come to canada
canadians wants to be able to travel
and when they they are coming back they
don't want to go to
a hotel current in a jail
you know for 14 days so
that's still in force and we were asking
we did that protest to ask the federal
government to stop that
actually it was interesting because we
were able to
to do the main
media u.s media
in buffalo i was on the tv in buffalo
over there and in the newspaper over
there
but the canadians and mainstream media
didn't didn't cover that they didn't
cover that so
that's another example of the we've been
canceled
we don't want to speak about that but
answering your question
yes it's still in force and the
government is telling us that maybe in a
couple of
weeks it won't be a it won't be the case
anymore
but uh i don't believe them that's why
we did that process and i can tell you
that
it's unfair and there are some families
that are living on both side of the
border
in the state of new york and
and ontario near niagara they cannot see
their family and they were not
able to see their family for the last
year um
so we must stop that and it's very bad
for the economy in canada it's very bad
for the economy in the u.s
um so there's no reason there's no
reason it's not
now all the decisions from these
governments
are not based on science are not based
on science
and and and did they like to control the
population
i think they they appreciate the fact
that under this
uh health emergency order that every
province passed
uh politicians like the power that they
have uh
there's no debate in our parliament uh
at the provincial and federal level
there's no debate because if you are in
the opposition
a political party that is sitting in the
opposition and your goal is to be in
government
when 60 and 65 percent of the population
likes these kind of measures you don't
want to have these 65
that's 65 percent of the population
against you
so you're silent and that's why you
don't have any debate right now
in provincial uh um parliaments
and a different level um but like i said
you know
we know that the common sense will
prevail and we need to be out there and
to speak
and so i hope i hope that this summer
it will be behind us but i doubt
you sound more optimistic than me yeah
like well after watching this go on
for so long and people
actually ask for more lockdowns even
though they don't work
like oh i don't even know what to do now
like how can you
beat that if your own population is
asking to continue lockdowns that don't
work
like how do you fight that but actually
they wanted more lockdowns because also
you know at the same time that the
trudeau government
were giving you money not to work and
because of that
we have a huge deficit in ottawa 350
billion dollars
and and we are paying for that right now
people
thought that you know okay i'll stay at
home i'll have that check
uh everything is good and you know that
virus is
so dangerous and that you know i
appreciate what my government is doing
but we know the virus is not dangerous
if
it's not dangerous if you're in shape if
you're young
uh if you're under 30 years old uh the
chances to
to have uh to die from the seasonal flu
is more important than your chances to
die from coughing 19
and we know that 80 percent of the
deaths in our country
are coming from older people with
comorbidities
so so if you're young and in shape you
don't need to
you can do your life and do what you
want to do and go outside
you know i like to run i'm a runner i
was running last morning in montreal
early in the morning i saw another
runner maybe i'm 58 years old
maybe 25 years old running with a mask
running with a mask can you believe uh
how the population is scared about that
virus
so that's why you know um they're
supporting these
these measures and all the money that
the federal government
spend to scare people uh that was
effective
and and now
we we need to do the opposite and
and we cannot we and and they think that
all the money that they receive
all the checks that they receive from
the federal government because
the federal government gave strong
incentives to provincial
governments to go on with these
lockdowns because
the federal government said to
provincial governments
uh you know we will pay for your
financial
loss because of your lockdowns we will
reimburse you so that's why we have a
huge deficit
but we are paying now because we
we have in canada the trudeau inflation
tax
inflation is a tax it's a hidden tax and
if you go
do your grocery in canada right now you
it's there's about four or five percent
inflation
so the federal government won't tax you
for all and for to pay back this big
deficit
they are not honest what they're doing
they're saying to the population keep
your money in your own pockets keep your
money it's okay
but instead of taking your money by
taxing you
we'll let you your money but you won't
be able to buy the same amount of good
and
goods and services with that money your
purchasing power will go down
the inflation will go up and everybody
will be poorer
so that's happening right now we are
paying the trudeau inflation tax
and to that's uh and and people must
realize that
so that's why you know that would be
important to inform people
or educate people about all the impact
of these uh draconian measures
that make sense what what are your
stances on
other conservative issues like
immigration and abortion
yeah first of all on abortion our party
doesn't have any position it's a
conscience a question
and everybody would be free to vote you
know
uh in in a parliament you when you're a
member of parliament
you have the privilege of tabling a bill
on a bill on any subject and if
one of our candidate is elected and
if that person is pro-life or pro-choice
and if that person is pro-life for
example and want to table a bit on
abortion
that would be allowed we will have a
debate on abortion in this country
and we'll see what will happen you know
i cannot stop the member of parliament
to table a bill
on any subject uh so i'm very honest
with the population
and but for for the party we don't have
any position on that
uh so but but i don't know what can
happen
uh i know that in my i have some
candidates that are pro-choice i have
some candidate in my
in my party that have a pro-life and
and maybe if they want to reopen the
debate maybe we'll have a debate on
abortion in canada
if uh some people elected um
some of our candidates that are pro-life
but it's it must be a free vote
and everybody must be able to and no
no party line on that and i think that's
important and like that you'll have a
real debate in parliament so that's our
position on
on on abortion actually we don't have
any position
and everybody will be free to vote if
there's a if there's a bill
on abortion but we if we form the
government
won't a ball a bit on abortion that
won't be
something that won't be in our platform
it's not in our platform it's not
something that we will do
if we if if we are the government but
maybe a private member bill it's a bill
that a member
of parliament table not sponsored by the
government
that can happen so i'm honest with with
the canadians
and i'm saying that you know our party
is not um
taking any position on abortion uh on
the uh
on immigration you you have a great
question because we are the only
party in ottawa that is against the
mass immigration and for sustainable
immigration
as you know the trudeau government want
to increase uh
wants to increase the uh the immigration
level
to uh 400 000 uh newcomers a year
and we and and they doubled the refugees
right now
and the double also people coming on the
reunification of family
what we want we want fewer immigrants
but skill immigrants we want immigrants
that will come here
under the economic immigrant status
so they will come here because they will
have a job because
for example an entrepreneur is if an
entrepreneur is not able to find a
canadian for that job
that entrepreneur has the right to look
all across the world and if you find
somebody
and that person will come we call that
an economic immigrant
a still immigrant we want more than we
want more skilled immigrant
fewer refugees and actually all the
refugees
that that are supposed to be refugees
that are crossing the border in quebec
at the roxanne road are not refugees
you know they are crossing the border at
the ill an illegal
point of enter and and the
they claim that they are refugees but i
don't believe when you're coming from
the state of new york that your life
isn't it's in danger
so the federal government is helping to
have more fake refugees
and is not helping the real refugees
that are waiting in a camp somewhere
in the world so so our policy would be
to help the real refugees and stop
people coming by the rock some road in
quebec
so they don't cross the official point
of enter
because if they cross that canada and us
we have an an agreement together if a
person is claiming to be a refugees and
crossing
the official point of enter that person
will have to go back to the us
because you know us is not a dangerous
country
and so so now that's why they're not
crossing at the official point of enter
they're crossing in the middle of the
wood
called the roxanne road and and they're
claiming that they're refugees
and the federal government said okay you
will come
but we must just put a fence over there
and stop that
and asking them to cross at the official
point of entry
and like that they will have to go back
to the us because they're not real
refugees so
our position on immigration is fewer
immigrants
people must come here to sh and they
must share our canadian values
we must be able to have an interview
with them uh you know
40 years ago we had an interview with
every
uh immigrant uh that want to
that wants to come to canada and now we
don't have that anymore so
we must have an interview with them we
must have a questionnaire about their
values
they must share our values that you know
men and women are equal
before the law uh you know we are in a
free country
we respect we have a constitution we
have rights and freedom in this country
so so that would be important but
instead of having 400 000 people a year
we want to go back to the average that
we had
under the upper government about 150
000 immigrants a year with uh
maybe 60 70 percent of them being
uh economic immigrants uh fewer
people coming on the reunification of
family and fewer people coming under
a refugee so and by the way we are the
only party
that has a position like that the
conservative the liberal and
all the other political parties want uh
want more more immigrant and more
immigrant and
i think we saw a poll last week
that 45 percent of canadians are asking
for fewer immigrants
and 59 of conservative voters
are asking for fewer immigrants and so
we are the only one
the conservative uh don't you know
like i said in the beginning they're
going to the left they're like the
liberals and they're happy with more and
more and more
so that would be an important subject
because i like our country
i want our country to be like that in 25
years
i don't want our country to be like in
france
there are some ghettos over there where
the the law of the land
does not apply there and we must not
have that in canada
so that's why we must have a debate on
immigration
and our position is clear and actually
if
canadians uh if if for a canadian
is it is very important to have fewer
immigrants
their only option is us at the people's
party of canada
so what's the difference at the moment
between the conservative party and the
liberal party
or are they both kind of going for the
same thing at this point but
okay we just talked about immigration
they're the same
uh lockdowns they're the same uh not
doing anything to build pipelines in
this country that would be important for
the prosperity and the unity of our
country
they're the same they don't want to use
the constitution
we have a section 9210 in our
constitution and if you use that
the federal government will have full
authority to build pipelines
all across this country so they are like
the liberals on the paris accord
they're like the liberals you know they
they they signed the paris accord
uh they will impose carbon tax they will
impose more regulation on businesses
we are against the paris accord we won't
impose a carbon tax we won't impose more
regulations
you know the beauty of our constitution
in canada
the environment is a shared jurisdiction
with provinces
so if if it's so important for a premier
of a province to fight climate change
that premiere will be able to do that
you know so but us
at the federal level we won't have any
policy
uh on the climate change but the
conservative they are like the liberals
um i can go on with the equalization
formula in canada the equalization
formula it's a formula that
rich provinces are giving money to poor
provinces
for for canadians to have the kind of
same
level of public services from their
government
but um the the alberta and other
provinces are giving a lot of money
to uh to uh poor provinces in our
country
but the conservatives don't want to
to speak about it we have a position on
that we must
change the equalization formula to be
fair for every province and be less
generous and like that it would give the
right incentive
to poor provinces like quebec and like
new brunswick to develop their own
natural resources
now there's no incentive to develop
their own natural resources because they
received
a lot of money from the equalization
formula so they are the same on that
on the fighting um uh hate speech
built to c36 like i said the
conservative has they
have the same position of the liberals
so that's why i'm saying
their liberal light their likelihoods
their goal is to split the liberal votes
so they have policies that are
like the liberals uh policies uh
i can go on you know i think i give you
five or six examples of that
uh on the budget another exam the
federal budget
utool said that he will he will he will
balance the budget in 10 years
but when you go for an election you ask
the population to give you a mandate of
four years
monday so what is telling the population
is you know
he'll do that in 10 years he won't do it
he's saying the same thing then
then just thank you justin to know the
liberal said he won't balance the budget
for him it's not
important so tool is saying the same
thing you're 10 years so in 10 years
you know you won't build a garden and
you won't balance the budget
we are different we said that we want to
balance the budget in four years in one
mandate
to be sure to get rid of these
huge deficit so on the deficit they are
the same
i can go on and go on but i think you
have a lot of example now
wow okay that's definitely concerning
well i think that covers what i wanted
to bring you on to talk about
who's covid what your party is trying to
achieve and
who you are so that was interesting
thank you very much
for coming on if people want to learn
more about you where can they go to find
you they can go to our website
people's party of canada that see all
our platform our policies
is there and i want them to not forget
that we are doing politics differently
because we are doing politics based on
principles like i said in the beginning
individual freedom personal
responsibility respect and fairness and
all our policies
are in line with these principles and so
the platform that we are running
on for the next election is the same
platform that we run on in 2019
and that would be the same platform in
2024
you know we are speaking about bold
reforms
that we need to do in this country to
have a smaller government in ottawa that
will respect the constitution
respect the taxpayers give more autonomy
to provinces
and like that will have more freedom so
that's the people's party of canada
and if they want to know more people's
party of canada that see
i really appreciate mikaela that you
gave me that time to
explain our platform and policies
well thanks for coming on that was very
interesting
thank you have a nice day have a nice
[Music]
day
you